bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale
on commence tout de suite avec les
grandes lignes de cette émission le plan
social de eads aura de fortes
conséquences sur l'emploi 1700 postes
supprimés en france qu'en est-il dans le
département et l'encours euros
le point dans un instant les patrons
d'entreprises en colère et notamment
ceux du secteur du bâtiment un secteur
qui souffrirait notamment de concurrence
déloyale
une délégation était reçue ce lundi par
le préfet et 15 impact économique à
l'activité nucléaire dans le département
nos invités jean louis tison président
de la société française d'énergie
nucléaire dans les yvelines bonsoir fera
face à jean-luc montceau bonsoir vous
êtes de secrétaire départemental
d'europe écologie les verts
vous nous apporterez donc du coup votre
point de vue dans un instant et en avant
cela on passe à l'actualité économique
de la semaine
la direction de eads a annoncé en début
de semaine la suppression des 5800 poste
dont 1700 en france en cause une
nouvelle stratégie pour ses activités
défense et espace et le regroupement
d'entités selon les estimations 360
postes seraient supprimés dans la
filiale cassidian et ils 1170 pour
astrium dans le pays dans les trois
prochaines années
ces deux filiales sont particulièrement
présentes dont le barde département le
site des mureaux compte 1900 salariés
celui de cassidian 1600 le syndicat cfc
gse se montre mobilisés et attend le
conseil d'entreprise de demain pour y
voir plus clair
pour le moment ils ne savent pas encore
quel site seront épargnés c'est ça notre
grand problème parce que pour cassidian
par exemple quand on annonce 360 cas
s'il ya en france c'est environ 2500
personnes mais dans aller une dizaine de
structures juridiques différentes donc
aujourd'hui moi je suis représentant
cassidian sas je sais pas si les 360
c'est chez cassidian et crs ou si c'est
dans nos filiales aussi donc aujourd'hui
on n'a aucun détail sur ça on a eu un
chiffre brut 360 points les sites des
mureaux et d'elancourt pourrait se voir
renforcée par l'arrivée de salariés
actuellement présent sur de plus petites
structures d'ile-de-france pas forcément
le bon choix pour les salariés selon
philip glass quand groupe des gens ici
ça peut être coûté moins cher en
structure nous déjà on s'est installé
dans cours avant on était
huit sites en région ile de france donc
on a regroupé ici pour que ça coûte
moins cher mon visiblement ça coûte
toujours aussi cher et donc on veut
encore regrouper d'autres gens oui c'est
vrai que louer des bâtiments à suresnes
c'est peut-être plus cher qu à l encours
aux mureaux d'un autre côté on veut
faire déménager de gens de la banlieue
nord de paris jusqu à l encours est là
en terme de transports pour les gens ça
va pas être très simple les patrons
d'entreprises et notamment du secteur du
bâtiment en colère et très inquiet dans
le cadre d'un mouvement unitaire au
groupement regroupant pardon la
fédération du bâtiment la cgpm la
chambre des métiers là l'unique ils ont
été reçus lundi par le préfet
reportage de catherine plateau et
jonathan vilma réunis autour d'une même
table et parlant d'une même voix ses
représentants divine loi de la
fédération du bâtiment de la cgpme ou de
la chambre des métiers réclame des
règles claires plus de lisibilité dans
les actions du gouvernement et une
pérennité des décisions il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui vu le climat freine
les investissements n'embauchent pas
alors qu'ils pourraient le faire et donc
je crois que le il faut qu'on arrive à
recréer un climat de confiance les chefs
d'entreprise si vous voulez ne savent
pas quelles sont les nouvelles taxes qui
vont sortir les lois l'art et autres
rétroactivité des lois
donc on joue un jeu sans avoir la règle
du jeu donc on joue plus il ya un
ras-le-bol de la part de nos adhérents
un d entreprise quelle qu'elle soit
aussi bien petit que moyenne que
importante sur toutes les charges qui
sont promus
d'une manière cohérente c'est à dire que
vous voyez nous sommes le le 10 décembre
la tva on ne sait pas exactement donc
avec quelles modalités elle va
s'appliquer le 1er janvier c'est le
conte pénibilité qu'il a à mon avis le
la chose la plus grave pour 2014 puisque
nous allons devoir remplir une fiche de
paie de pénibilité par personne et par
jour
en cause également la loi sur la
délocalisation du personnel les fameux
salariés détachés en france ils étaient
2000 il ya 15 ans et aujourd'hui ils
seraient plus de 200000 le patronat
parle de concurrence déloyale et demande
des règles on peut pas revenir sur la
loi de la libre circulation mais il ya
des barrières qui peuvent être à dire
exigé par exemple que les salariés
soient bien déclaré paye bien les
charges sociales dans leur pays
d'origine et bien des congés payés
travaillent avec des heures
supplémentaires ce qui n'est pas le cas
on s'aperçoit que ce qu'on nous offre
c'est des gens qui travaillent 50 70
heures par semaine
ce mouvement unitaire du patronat yves
binois été reçue par le préfet depuis le
mois de septembre
autre signe inquiétant selon eux on voit
de plus en plus d'entreprises
expérimentés affichant dix ans
d'ancienneté fermer boutique
on ne peut pas accepter de se faire tuer
sans rien dire a prévenu jeudi les
commerçants choqué le centre commercial
et des gâtines à plaisir a été ravagé
par un incendie dimanche vers 5 heures
du matin au total cinq commerces ont été
gravement touchés le sinistre
s'élèveraient à plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros
la thèse d'un acte prémédité sera
envisagée par les commerçants eux mêmes
une enquête est en cours et travaux
devraient durer huit mois
en attendant la réouverture les
commerces pourraient être relogées dans
des préfabriqués ou des chalets en bois
sur le parking alors que la sncf est
aujourd'hui en grève le stif le syndicat
des transports d'île de france a voté
hier son budget 2014 et a annoncé
quelques nouveautés pour l'année à venir
au niveau des tarifs les tickets et
abonnements devraient augmenter de 3%
soit la répercussion nato hausse de la
tva sur les transports cela exception
est une bonne nouvelle pour ceux qui
travaillerait à paris le pass navigo
zones 1 à 5 restera au même prix pour
les autres ils pourront profiter d'un
des zonages plus important toutes les
vacances scolaires
en plus des week-ends et jours fériés et
puis des tarifs unifiée dans les
cantines des lycées c'est ce que propose
la région ile-de-france une tarification
basée sur le quotient familial des repas
compris entre 1 et 4 euros le dispositif
existe déjà pour les collèges
franciliens il sera appliqué à partir de
la rentrée 2014 est disponible dans tous
les établissements de la région
dans cinq ans et puis on ferme finit par
une initiative de la ferme de grignon
elle a lancé le premier drive laitiers
en france les premières livraisons ont
eu lieu vendredi dernier
son but aller à la rencontre de ses
clients
reportage antoine fait partie des
premiers clients de ce drive laitiers
vendredi dernier ils venaient chercher
ses produits laitiers sur ce bord de
route
après avoir passé commande sur le site
internet de la ferme de grignon cette
ferme expérimentale temps ici une
initiative originale apporter des
produits frais directement à leurs
clients
ce camion frigorifique s'est installé au
croisement des routes départementales en
contrebas de la ferme
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait plus
de 26000 voitures qui passaient devant
la ferme et qui s'arrêtaient pas
forcément à notre boutique
on s'est rendu compte que souvent les
gens sont sur des trajets domicile
travail rentrent chez eux ils n'ont pas
forcément le temps de venir dans la
ferme de s'arrêter d'aller voir la
boutique de faire la queue et souvent il
ya des enfants dans la voiture sortir
les enfants ça prend du temps voilà donc
on a voulu faire un service offrira
service ces gens là pour que ce soit
plus rapide pour cette première en
france
une vingtaine de personnes a passé
commande les produits phares yaourt et
faycelles les livraisons s'effectuent
pour le moment tous les vendredis de 16h
à 20h si le concept fonctionne les
points de livraison pourraient se
multiplier et l'offre s'élargir des
bières artisanales aux caisses est gagné
l'entretien est consacré cette semaine
aux impacts économiques du nucléaire
nous recevons sur ce plateau jean louis
tison président de la société française
d'énergie nucléaire dans le département
bonsoir et j'en remercie d'être venus
jean-luc montceau co secrétaire
départemental d'europe écologie les
verts
bonsoir alors que vous avez tous deux
forcément des avis qui diffèrent on va
tout d'abord peut-être faire un point
sur la situation dans le département où
je commence avec vos jambes et izon on
compte pas de centrales dans les
yvelines
on y trouve tout de même quatre pôles
liées au nucléaire ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire un peu plus bien sûr
effectivement les yvelines sont pour un
département spécial vendu clair on a
près de nous le centre de saclay les
soldes qui contient plusieurs milliers
d'emplois mais pour ce qui est du
nucléaire dans les yvelines on a cherché
à recenser les emplois directs de
nucléaire dans les yvelines et on a
trouvé effectivement le 4 pôles
importants
chatou et edf le vésinet avec l'institut
de radioprotection et de sûreté
nucléaire
et beaucoup d'emplois
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 900 à saint
quentin en yvelines sur un total de 1800
emplois que nous avons identifiées sur
l'ensemble des yvelines alors on se rend
compte principalement en fait un des
postes d'ingénieurs de chercheurs ou des
post alliés aux transports notamment
donc vous indiquez 1800 emplois directs
et 900 emplois en direct les emplois
indirects qui concerne ciel mais lille
on pourrait dire est que ce sont les
services associés aux entreprises
il y en a il ya toujours de l'aide
demandée
pour des sous-traitants ou autres sont
des emplois indirects d'accord après
jean-luc un verseau vous affichez donc
clairement pour l'arrêt du nucléaire
weepu tendance à l'imitation est ce que
vous vous prouver que ces chiffres du
coup ce sont trop faibles pour les
prendre en compte que ça n'a pas
l'impact économique ou au contraire
qu'on peut être que les échos les
nouvelles énergies en fait on pourrait
apporter plus d'emplois si tel est votre
position par rapport à ça alors on peut
pas dire effectivement que nucléaire
n'ait pas d'impact économique ça serait
vraiment le minimiser dans les yvelines
effectivement ça représente assez peu
d'emplois mais au niveau national quand
même quelques dizaines de milliers
d'emplois ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est
qu'avec la diminution du nucléaire qui
est programmé donc la baisse à 50% du
nucléaire dans le production
d'électricité en france qui est prévu
pour demander un grave
voilà exactement ça va occasionner bien
évidemment des diminutions d'emploi dans
le nucléaire mais ça va être largement
compensée par une augmentation d'emplois
dans les énergies renouvelables dans les
systèmes d'efficacité énergétique
on parlait tout à l'heure du bâtiment
dans tous les systèmes de rénovation du
bâtiment et donc il ya une étude très
sérieuse qui est paru il ya quelques
mois qui mentionne qu'à l'horizon 2025
il s'agit plutôt avec toute cette
transition énergétique puisqu'on parle
bien de cette transition énergétique
globalement et pas simplement le secteur
du nucléaire
cette transition énergétique à l'horizon
2025 représentera 440 mille emplois donc
ce n'est pas rien 440 mille emplois
quand on a 3 millions de chômeurs en
france pour l'instant 125 mille postes
en france liées au nucléaire 90 milles
son contrôle
les emplois indirects donc effectivement
ce ne serait pas non plus si peu gens
utilisant ou vous pensez plutôt que
l'arrêt du nucléaire auraient des
impacts plutôt négatif alors ce qu'il
faut s'il faut que l'on ait des emplois
compétitif et le nucléaire est un source
d'énergie compétitif il ya eu un rapport
de la cour des comptes ans en 2012 qui a
estimé le coût du kilowattheure
nucléaire est le premier enseignement de
ce rapport de la cour des comptes ça a
été de dire on connaît bien le coût du
kilowattheure nucléaire parce que c'est
long la dépense pour fabriquer un coût
du kilowattheure nucléaire c'est long il
faut s'occuper du combustible construire
la centrale faire fonctionner la
centrale s'occuper de son démantèlement
s'occuper de la gestion des déchets la
chaîne est longue mais ce qui a été
estimé par la cour des comptes si qu'on
avait une estimation très bonne très
précise avec très peu d'incertitude sur
ce coup du nucléaire du kilowattheure
nucléaire qui est évalué va pas faire
beaucoup de chiffres mais il est évalué
à 50 euros du mégawattheures et le
deuxième enseignement qui a été donné
dans cette étude par la cour des comptes
et puis le rapport
mandil également de 2012 il ce rapport a
établi que le coût du kilowattheure
nucléaires tels que je viens de vous le
dire et le plus faible de toutes les
autres sources d'énergie alors ce soit
mon avis pouvoir voir à l'écran du coup
elle le tableau dont vous parlez oui
16eme visible mais que ce que l'on
remarque c'est que le nucléaire
dans une fourchette de 43,75 voilà
l'hydroélectricité est autour de 55 le
gaz naturel beaucoup plus élevé et puis
l'éolien l'éolien offshore les énergies
renouvelables coûte beaucoup plus cher
alors moi j'entends monsieur manceau qui
dit on va créer des emplois et on va
faire des kilowattheures éolien la
contrepartie est la conclusion la
conséquence de ces emplois c'est que on
va avoir un kilowattheure qui va coûter
très cher aujourd'hui les entreprises
bénéficient grâce au nucléaire à un
accès à l'énergie 30% moins cher qu'en
allemagne par exemple ou en grande
bretagne
les les particuliers allemands les
particuliers allemands payent leur
électricité deux fois plus cher qu'en
france
alors si c'est ça que l'on veut
aujourd'hui c'est pas raisonnable de
dire on va on va faire et créer des
emplois dans tous les sens la première
conséquence de ça c'est un coût du
kilowattheure un coût de l'électricité
beaucoup plus élevé et on s'entraide
assez voilà pour les 25 également
présents trappe rien su et à ce moment
là on fait des emplois aidés ce qui est
important dans le nucléaire aujourd'hui
c'est que ce sont des emplois compétitif
qui aident à la compétitivité de la
france il faut maintenir cette
compétitivité alors également la parole
un tableau que ça vient de votre part la
guerre des chiffres comme ça des sources
peut-être que le voir à l'écran voilà
des mois qu'il rejoigne y en a qui sera
jane effectivement c'est pas
complètement incohérent ceci dit
effectivement je m'inscris en faux par
rapport au coût du nucléaire
le rapport de la cour des comptes après
prenez en compte effectivement les
provisions d'edf pour le démantèlement
des centrales nucléaires
mais dans un autre paragraphe un peu
plus loin la cour des comptes faisait
remarquer que cette provision étaient
insuffisantes
donc si on prend une provision
suffisante et correspondant notamment à
un retour d'expérience en angleterre en
allemagne même en france la centrale
nucléaire de brennilis en bretagne son
démantèlement coûte beaucoup beaucoup
plus cher 20 fois plus cher que ce qui
était prévu initialement
donc le
du coup ni kilowattheure enfin du
mégawatt heure nucléaire et serait
plutôt en haut de la fourchette
mentionnée dans le tableau précédent
plutôt même peut-être même à 90 euros le
mégawattheure et donc à 90 euros le
mégawattheure c'est clair que du coup ça
devient la même ordre de grandeur que
l'éolien terrestre qui à 81 que le
photovoltaïque qui actuellement à 100 à
peu près mais la caractéristique de
l'éolien et du photovoltaïque c'est que
ce sont des coûts en baisse alors que le
coût du nucléaire compte tenu des
problèmes de sécurité qui sont de plus
en plus importants et voilà les coûts
aussi de retraitement des déchets qu'on
a toujours pas résolu ne peuvent
qu'aller à la hausse par rapport à ce
qui était prévu
donc ça c'est une première chose et une
deuxième chose c'est que parts par
million d'euros par euro investi le
nucléaire est beaucoup plus beaucoup
moins créateurs d'emplois que les
énergies renouvelables puisque pour le
nucléaire d'ailleurs comme pour le
pétrole
on est parent millions d'euros donc à
3-3 emplois créés alors que on est à 15
16 pour pour les énergies renouvelables
ou là les
la rénovation la rénovation des
bâtiments donc il ya vraiment un effort
important apporté non pas sûr donc
toujours produire plus mais avant tout
réduire les consommations d'énergie
c'est bien ça d'enjeux importants
je vous laisse le mot de la fin sur ces
énergies renouvelables vous n'êtes pas
forcément opposé à son développement
l'économie d'énergie nous sommes tout à
fait partisan de faire des économies
d'énergie il faut également encourager
les énergies renouvelables sont
d'ailleurs subventionné actuellement
nous notre proposition c'est de
maintenir un socle nucléaire très fort
très puissant en france parce que il
rapporte des devises il rend les
entreprises plus plus compétitive et on
en a besoin véritablement en france je
remercie tous les deux on n'aura pas
réussi à vous mettre d'accord mais au
moins on a entendu hors de propos merci
à vous d'être revenu en place tout de
suite
c'est le moment des fameux marché de
noël est l'occasion pour les visiteurs
de faire quelques achats avant les fêtes
mais aussi pour les commerçants et
artisans de mettre en valeur leurs
produits et d'approcher de plus près les
clients nous nous sommes intéressés aux
aspects économiques de ces marchés de
noël
yolande thorez et patrick de dixmude se
sont rendus sur les marchés de saint cyr
l'école et de plaisir
reportage le refrain est connu depuis
huit ans à saint cyr l'école le fameux
marché noël s'installe pour deux jours
deux jours qui nécessite un long travail
d'organisation la mairie de la ville s'y
attellent jusqu'à 6 mois al avance dont
trois mois de préparation intensive
une des premières étapes le choix des
commerçants à saint cyr l'école on
sélectionne uniquement des
professionnels
on cherche à soutenir je sais que la
municipalité voulait vraiment soutenir
l'activité économique de la ville et
donc si on devait accepter de nombreux
particuliers
malheureusement il y aurait beaucoup
trop de concurrence après peut-être pour
les petits artisans ou les jeunes d'auto
entrepreneur donc c'est vrai qu'on
s'étonne que les commerçants maintenant
il ya aussi beaucoup de commerçants de
province qui viennent parce que bon
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de producteurs de
foie gras saint si on n'a pas des
éleveurs et de charcutiers sur saint cyr
donc non après on a beaucoup de
commerçants de l'extérieur mais on
sélectionne uniquement les commerçants
parmi les commerçants de province
justement les joyaux du périgord ont été
sollicités pour la première fois sur ce
marché il regroupe sous leur marque
différents producteurs de leur région
c'est surprenant
un marché comme celui là représentent 3
à 4% de leur chiffre d'affaires annuel
foie gras chocolat ou encore spiritueux
une centaine de produits sont proposés
sur leur stand un pouvoir aussi
promotionner notre entreprise sur le
département
aujourd'hui on attend dans à peu près
4000 personnes donc on espère faire sur
le week-end 3000 euros quand le chiffre
d'affaires d'autres ne parle pas de
chiffre d'affaires mais plutôt de fonds
récoltés
l'association et zadco sera basée à
fontenay le fleury travaille à
l'insertion dans la vie sociale et
professionnelle des malades psychiques
adultes comme la trentaine de
commerçants présents ce week end
l'association a loué son emplacement au
prix de 10 euros le mètre linéaire
on est venus en plus à saint cyr
pour permettre tout simplement qu'ils
aient une vue que ce qu'ils font peut
être vendu et peut être bien vendu on va
récolter un peu de fond est remis pour
les usagers dans ce qu'on appelle une
petite cagnotte pour leur séjour ils ont
fait un séjour chaque année à plaisir on
n'y trouve près de cinquante commerçants
les visiteurs sont des habitués ils
viennent surtout pour la tradition mais
aussi pour approcher les petits artisans
je trouve que le d'abord les produits et
délicieux et puis et puis les prix n'ont
pas n'ont pas bougé donc voilà je suis
satisfaite je retrouve mes commerçants
artisans
je pense que c'est intéressant et puis
ça permet aussi de faire travailler les
petits producteurs et les groupes du
terral l'artisanat moines où souvent on
regarde les petits stands du les bijoux
les deux petites fantaisies
ocado pour pour la famille voilà avant
cela
passage obligé par l'étape installations
et répartition des emplacements la
veille du marché le coaching
jacky boisseau apiculteurs de plaisir
s'empresse de s'installer il décharge sa
cinquantaine de kilos de miel et sa
quarantaine de kilos de pain d épice 90
euros pour les deux jours c'est le prix
de son emplacement
un prix qu'il juge raisonnable
aujourd'hui à l'époque il nous affirme
que c'était le doublé je suis habitants
de plaisir je viens donc proposer mes
produits je pense que un marché de noël
doit rester dans un prix raisonnable si
on veut effectivement qu'il y ait de la
clientèle et le prix d'un stand se
répercute dans le prix d'un produit et
donc des petits artisans qui font des
bijoux qui font des créations lorsque le
prix d'entrée le ticket d'entrée est à
160 170 180 euros ça ne passe plus dans
le budget pour amortir ensuite dans la
vente de colliers ou de produits
diverses cargaisons fidèles de ce marché
de noël jacky y vend ses produits depuis
7 ans n'ayant pas de boutique c'est
grâce à son réseau et à ce genre de
marché qu'il écoule ses productions il
ne fait pas de statistiques mais estime
que les ventes ici représente environ
30% de son marché annuel à quelques
mètres de là le standard mans luxe se
prépare quelques clients sont venus
avant l'heure
depuis le mois de mai l'enseignant
ouvert une boutique à plaisir ce marché
de noël représente 15 à 20% de leur
chiffre d'affaires sur l'année pour
cette marque de vêtements et
d'alimentation bretonne c'est aussi
l'occasion de se faire connaître
n'a plus accès au niveau du public donc
ça nous permet à vendre beaucoup plus ça
pour un stand de 9 mètres de long le
magasin paye 247 euros pour les deux
jours
juste en face nous retrouvons le
vigneron paul garzaro depuis huit ans il
fait le déplacement de bordeaux pour ce
marché
nombreux sont ses clients dans les
environs alors chaque année ils en
profitent pour venir vendre son vin il
est envoyé 380 invitations par mail pour
près de 800 bouteilles en stock
alex turner le 78 des quelques enfin
tout le département
et ça permet de recontacter avant les
fêtes pour renouveler leurs cales se
permet en même temps de faire venir du
monde supplémentaire parce que j'ai pas
connecté en 1818
je les clients de paris qui viennent se
ravitailler ci qui aiment pas les
grosses foires et qu'il peut faire
quelque chose de plus intime la france
compte aujourd'hui 37 marché officiel
permanent et sur plusieurs semaines
l'hexagone est alors le deuxième pays
européen en nombre de marchés de noël
loin derrière l'allemagne etc 2234
adresse mais devant la grande bretagne
et pour finir l'agenda de dates à
retenir convaincront entretiens de
recrutement un atelier organisé le 17
décembre de 14 heures à 17 heures à la
cité des métiers à trappes
vous pourrez vous entraîner à vous
passer des entretiens et avoir le retour
de professionnels pour les personnes
intéressées par la création d'entreprise
la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
vous propose un atelier pour se
familiariser avec les étapes clés et se
lancer dans l aventure
au programme notamment les démarches la
faisabilité de votre projet les
organismes et aide de financement rendez
vous le 19 décembre de 14 heures à 17
heures c'est la fin de ce fil est qu
merci de nous avoir suivis bonne soirée
et à la semaine prochaine